any tariffs on Mexican goods are likely
to push up costs for American consumers
and businesses Dean Reynolds spoke to
one businessman in Chicago who says the
price of food could skyrocket dean what
else did he tell you good morning well
Peter testa the president of testa
produce says there are certain foods
especially during the wintertime that
you can only get from Mexico because of
their climate now putting a tariff on
those products he warns could create a
snowball effect that will be felt by
every American this is all for Mexico
okay this whole pound as we walked with
Peter testa through his company's vast
91 thousand square foot produce
warehouse we quickly understood why he's
a little anxious these days probably
eighty ninety percent of all the help he
knows in chief out in Chicago right now
are all Mexican grown with the Trump
administration threatening to impose new
tariffs on Mexican imports to force a
crackdown on illegal immigration it
means testa could soon have to pay more
to stock his shelves and so could his
customers grocery stores restaurants and
all of their customers you know
cucumbers watermelons green onion like
very blackberries yes bananas all this
is coming from Mexico surpassed Canada
and China this year as the United States
largest trade partner in 2018 the u.s.
imported nearly three hundred and
seventy two billion dollars worth of
goods and services from there and while
some of the biggest imports are
automobiles and vehicle parts the u.s.
brought in thirteen point four billion
dollars worth of fruits vegetables and
nuts they've been ripping us off from a
trade standpoint I think Mexico has been
absolutely fabulous partner I would not
fault them at all
I do not see the point in messing with a
great partner testa says there's no way
to painlessly adjust food is not a
discretionary purchase you don't have to
buy a car you don't have to buy an
iPhone you don't have to do that food
everybody eats
now take this avocado for example
avocados are the second largest fruit
export from Mexico to the United States
after tomatoes right now one of these
costs about a dollar 75 but if the
tariffs are imposed and rise potentially
to 25 percent by October as the
president has threatened the price of
this avocado would go well beyond beyond
$2 for just one of these and that's real
money
Tony Dean thank you very much it sounds
like it's time to stock up on avocados
this is the weekend to do it if only
they kept longer who doesn't love
avocado toast Tony you don't know there
are people